[Musique]
c'est de promouvoir le secourisme à
travers et des secours opérationnels
donc tous les secousses de la Croix
Blanche sont
qualifiés PS1 PSE2 monde dans les
ambulances et font les secours la
deuxième mission de la Croix Blanche
pacifiquement de promouvoir le
secourisme à travers des formations donc
formation que nous effectuons pour tout
type de population
[Musique]
de rester dans le domaine du secourisme
et ne pas agir sur la partie médicale là
effectivement c'est le rôle du Samu
d'intervenir
à tous les niveaux on donne une
attestation de formation mais chez les
enfants via un petit diplôme puisqu'on
fait on forme tous les classes de CM1 de
Saint-Cyr-l'École pour les particuliers
civils qui ont besoin du PSC1 prévention
ce cours civique de niveau 1 ils en ont
besoin pour des qualifications sportives
ou pour
un travail quelconque mais effectivement
ils reçoivent un diplôme et pour le
secourisme du travail il y a une petite
carte sauveteur secouriste du travail
qui est valable deux ans
[Musique]
des gens qui savent faire les gestes
c'est bien mais si c'est moi qui tombe
dans la rue j'aimerais bien
effectivement que chaque personne que je
suis amené à croiser que ça soit un
enfant un adulte un senior soit capable
d'effectuer les premiers gestes en plus
en plus sans ma conviction personnelle
c'est qu'effectivement ça va aussi dans
le cadre du civisme et de la citoyenneté